-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-winning
and Grammy-nominated
comedian and writer
you know from her work
on "Black-ish," "The Upshaws,"
and "Curb Your Enthusiasm."
Her scripted
comedy podcast series
"Trust Fall" is available
November 30th on Audible.
Please welcome back
to the show our friend
Wanda Sykes,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Wanda!
-Good to be back.
-Congratulations on
your Grammy nomination.
-Why, thank you.
-Yes, very, very exciting.
-It's my first one.
-It's your first
Grammy nomination?
-First Grammy nomination.
-That's very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
I feel like, you know,
I'm like a rock star now.
You know?
-Your twins are 14?
-Yes.
-I would think
they would be on the cusp
of wanting to go to the Grammys.
Do they want to go?
-Of course they want to go.
-Are you going to let them go?
-Hell, no.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Have you told them this?
-Um, I-I think
they see it on my face.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-They're like,
"Oh, that's so cool!
You're going to the Grammys?"
And I just do this -- "Uh-huh."
[ Laughter ]
See, that says...
-Yeah, yeah.
-..."You're not going," right?
They don't even have to ask.
-If you did bring them, would
you want to be seen with them?
-Would I want to be
seen with them?
-Or would you want to
put some distance
between you and your daught--
-No.
They will put distance
between me.
Yeah, like, Olivia will go try
to sit with Beyoncé
or something.
-Yeah, yeah.
-They would just leave me.
-Yeah. You can't bring them.
You absolutely can't.
-They would dust me.
-Now, at 14, obviously, they're
making choices for themselves.
What are they watching?
Like, are there things
they watch
that is confusing to you?
-I have no idea
what they're watching.
I walk by, and they --
And it's all, like, YouTube.
They watch stuff on YouTube,
and it's -- usually,
they're watching
other people do stuff.
[ Laughter ]
Like, they spend hours
watching this guy
play a video game.
[ Laughter ]
It makes no sense.
Like, "Why
are y'all watching this?"
And it was like,
"Well, it's kind of cool."
I'm like, "So, you're telling me
you're too damn lazy
to play this game yourself,
so you'd rather watch
somebody play the game for you?"
-It's so funny, too,
back in my day, it'd be like,
"You know, when I was young,
I played my own video game."
[ Laughter ]
I can't believe
that it's come to a point,
the thing my dad
was mad at me about,
I'm like, "You have no idea
how much worse it gets."
-Exactly. [ Laughs ]
-So much worse.
Now, your wife is French.
-Yes.
-And do you feel like
your kids are multicultural?
And are there times
where you can see
the French side of them
coming out more?
-My kids are barely American,
they're so French.
-And they grew up here.
-So French.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-And what part of them --
Where do you see the Frenchness
the most?
-Uh, just, like, the --
Well, of course, language
and, uh, humor.
My son has the same type of
humor as my wife.
-Yeah.
-Which means, a lot of it,
I don't get.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I will say --
and I hope your wife
doesn't take this
the wrong way --
It's very heartbreaking to me
that your kids
have Wanda Sykes as a mom,
and they are getting
a French sense of humor.
[ Laughter ]
That is a terrib--
That broke terribly for them.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
But you're like, "They've
learned cuisine from me --
Wanda Sykes," yeah.
-Right. Exactly.
You know what? You're right.
Yeah, exactly, exactly, yeah.
-Yeah, so, they're French.
Does that mean
they don't do American holidays?
Like, what are they excited
about Thanksgiving?
-They're excited about it,
but they're going to France.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Are you going to France?
-No.
-Okay.
-No, no.
It's Thanksgiving. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to my parents' house.
-That's great.
So you go to your parents' house
and they just go --
-They going to France.
-They go off with your wife
to France.
-I guess that's because
they have school off,
and it makes sense.
-Exactly, exactly, exactly.
-And do they not -- I mean,
obviously,
they've had Thanksgiving.
-Yeah, yeah.
-They just don't care about it
that much?
-Well, it's not --
No, they they do enjoy it.
But they, you know,
they love France
a little bit more
than eating some turkey.
They're like, "Ugh."
-Yeah, right, that's true.
-[ French accent ] Turkey --
I don't know.
Non, merci.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Wanda,
you're doing something here
that a 14-year-old --
-It's a -- It's not a chicken.
N'est pas poulet.
[ Speaking French ]
Turkey. Um, um...
Non, merci.
-Oh, my God,
if they're like that,
you must be so thankful
they're going to France.
[ Laughter ]
So, what is -- Growing up
in your house,
what does -- you're going
to see your parents.
So, what's a Sykes family
Thanksgiving like?
Is it a lot of people?
-[ Normal voice ] It used to be
a lot of people.
Now it's -- you know,
it'll be my parents
and my brother and sister-in-law
and, you know, my nephew.
So, yeah, it's like 8 of us,
10 of us, sometimes.
-Good.
-And it's always some strays.
You got to bring in
a stray or two.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so...
-It kind of cuts the tension
to have a couple outsiders.
-It does.
If they're all insiders,
then it's the family's fault
when you start having
a bad time.
-Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
-You got to have
a weird outsider
to be like,
"This would have been fine
if Weird Ken wasn't here."
-Yeah, and it keeps everybody
on their best behavior.
-Yeah.
-'Cause it's like, you know,
if you start talking about
some family stuff
and then it gets a little deep,
you go, [ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
"We got a stray,
we got a stray."
-Strays are very helpful.
-Yeah.
-"Let's not go there right now.
Let's --" Yeah.
-I think we're both thankful
of the fact
that both the strikes are over.
I know you're a member of both.
-Thank you. Yes.
-Both guilds.
-Absolutely.
-Did you go out?
Did you picket
during the strikes?
-I was out there picketing.
And I was in L.A., too,
you know?
It was just too daggone hot
to be out there.
I was like, "Walking with
a sign, we still doing this?
Feels like we should have
some better options than this.
Is this still effective?"
-It's so funny, yeah.
You're right, technology
has not broken through.
-Exactly. Like, how about
a strongly worded e-mail?
How about that?
[ Laughter ]
They seem to get the job done.
-Yeah.
-You know,
I don't understand this.
And then, you know, when --
But you know,
'cause you were out there, too,
and you know.
And people, still they're
our union brothers and sisters,
but they don't --
they want a selfie, right?
You were taking
a lot of selfies.
-They want to take
a lot of pictures.
-A lot of pictures.
-And they want it.
And then people from the guild
always want to get
a sound bite from you.
-Right, exactly. Yeah.
-And the thing is,
when I'm on strike,
I don't have my hair
and makeup people,
so it's a pretty
bad-looking scene.
-Right, right.
-I think, a lot of time,
I had a very hurtful thing
that people would take selfies,
and then I'd watch them
look at it and just delete it
when they saw
what I looked like.
[ Laughter ]
When did you get your SAG card?
What was your first acting job
where you joined the union?
-"Nutty Professor II."
-Wow! "Nutty Professor II."
-"Nutty Professor II,"
I got my SAG card.
Yeah, that was with, uh --
That was Eddie Murphy,
and I played Glodine.
I was a -- Was it
Glodine was her name?
Wait, I was the hairdresser.
-And did you get to work
with multiple Eddies?
-Yeah, I got to work with
with Mama Klump
and then the grandmother.
And you know, actually,
the father
came by the shop, too.
-Tour de force.
-So, I mean --
-I think, one of the greatest
acting performances of all time.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-Eddie is unbelievable.
-Eddie is amazing. Amazing.
And I say that I got
to work with him,
but, basically, I worked
with a bunch of tennis balls.
That's what I did.
-Right,
'cause they had to CGI him.
-Yes, yes.
By the way, it shows
what a good actor you are.
You could never have known
they were tennis balls.
-Yeah.
-I have a lot more to ask about.
We'll be right back
with more Wanda after this.